oh all right so Sarah dies and Abraham
makes a bargain with Hittites
to purchase a burial place for her and
they offer it as a gift and he insists
upon paying for it it's a little story
that basically indicates two things that
Abraham was the kind of guy that you
trust pretty much when you see him and
that even if something is offered to him
as a gift he's going to do everything to
be reciprocal about it and and so it's
not a massively important part of the
story but it's it's in keeping with the
same narrative flow and so ephraim who's
a hit it-- offers a burial place as a
gift and Abraham says no you know you
have to let me pay for it and Efron says
he will and that works out very well and
so he has a good burrial place for his
wife and then Abraham decides that Isaac
needs a wife and so he sends his eldest
servant to Mesopotamia to find a wife
for Isaac and there's a strange ritual
that's performed so it says in the story
that the servant places his hand under
Abraham's thigh to to swear but that
isn't really what it means it means that
he places his hand I don't know exactly
how to say this properly well use your
imagination how about that and the idea
is that as far as I can tell that he's
swearing on the future he's swearing on
future people it's something like that
so that that's sort of what testified
means right think about the route well
I'm not kidding I'm not kidding that is
what it that's that is the derivation
right it is the derivation so so so
anyways this is a serious issue so that
servant has to go and find Isaac a good
wife and he wants him to find Isaac a
wife who is willing to accept the same
fundamental belief system which is
something like the belief in
a god that's a unity rather than a
plurality you know the other thing that
Jung was very insistent upon was that
there was a relationship between
polytheism and psychological confusion
and monotheism and psychological
unification I really like that idea too
that you know that that what you're
trying to do because you are a plurality
that that's one of the things the
psychoanalysts we're really good at
figuring out that the cognitive
scientists haven't touched yet as far as
I could tell they're way behind the
psychoanalysts in that element of
thinking is that you are composed of sub
personalities which all have their own
desires and their own viewpoint their
own thoughts and their own perceptions
and they're in a war with each other
constantly maybe even a Darwinian war
it's been it's been portrayed that way
by certain neuroscientists and that that
one of the goals of life is to integrate
all of that plurality into a
hierarchical ethical structure that has
some canonical ethic at the pinnacle
right when we've talked a little bit
about that and it's not obvious what
should be at the pinnacle but we can
guess at it it's it's that which we
admire that's one way of thinking about
it it's that that describes fair play
across a sequence of games that's
another good way of thinking about it
it's it's the heroic ideal that's
another way of thinking about it but
it's it's combined with generosity you
know because the hero the mythological
hero goes out into the unknown and slays
the dragon and gets the gold but then
comes back to the community and
distributes what's found and so it's
courage plus generosity and and so all
of your all of that interior you're
struggling that you're doing is an
attempt to bang yourself against the
world with challenge constantly to hit
everything together like you're beating
on a piece of iron to to to cure it
let's say so that you don't you're not
an internal contradiction you're not
mass of competing gods something like
that because it's just too
psychologically stressful and hard on
everyone else and impossible for them to
get along with you if you're one thing
one moment and another thing another
mole
so so anyways Abraham insists that Isaac
find a wife from among people who are
likely to carry off forward the
monotheistic tradition and I'm not sure
that the monotheistic tradition is
actually indistinguishable is actually
distinguishable from the individualistic
tradition I think they might be the same
thing at different levels of analysis
you know so because individual means
undivided in some sense right to be an
individual means to be one thing and the
other thing that mitigates against the
idea of life as happiness is it isn't
obvious to me that it's happiness that
is what molds you and shapes you you
know it's something more like optimal
challenge voluntarily undertaken it's
something like that right and I think
that's echoed in the idea that everyone
has a moral obligation to raise their
cross something like that to accept the
fact of their mortality voluntarily
I believe that that's the case and I do
actually think that that's a
prerequisite to proper psychological
development because if you're not
willing to take your mortality on
voluntarily like if you're kicking and
fighting about it constantly
and you have every reason to don't get
me wrong then you can't act forthrightly
in the world right you're going to be
afraid and when you're afraid then you
can't voluntarily take on a challenge
and then if you can't take voluntarily
take on a challenge then you can't
develop and so again the life seems to
be something like if it's a proper life
is the voluntarily voluntary taking on
of great challenges and maybe that's
better than happiness like it's
certainly more noble you know it's not a
word we use very much anymore the idea
of nobility because we're so obsessed
with happiness but I think happiness is
a like if it comes along man great you
know wonderful don't don't take it
lightly or for granted because it's
fleeting but the idea that that's what
you should be for in some sense - seems
to me if that's what life is for then
maybe it shouldn't be maybe that's
correct
because that isn't what life is but it
also doesn't it isn't obvious to me that
that's what life should be you know I
mean if you really loved someone
like like your Sun let's say would you
say well I hope he has a happy life or
would you say I hope he accomplishes
great things it seems to me that that's
better the accomplishing of great things
and because that's admirable you know
it's like a happy person is a happy
person but a noble person is an
admirable person and and that's that's
better man and so maybe there are better
things than happiness and so you can't
judge being on the basis of the ratio of
suffering to pleasure something like
that it's and I don't think we do that I
don't believe we do that